hey there guys thanks for tuning in
today I'm gonna talk to you about how I
burned about 20 grand from making
Android apps something a little bit
different there
okay so to start with let's just say
this isn't an unmitigated success story
I've been making actual about three and
a half years so 20 grand sounds awesome
but when you look at it across two and a
half years three and a half years rather
it's not you know life-changing but it
is definitely a very nice supplementary
income and the great thing about app
development is that other than updates
once you've released the app and you've
got it on the store you're then able to
get this passive income rolling in as
people buy new apps you don't need
anything for it so that's been
supplementary income on top of my
writing work and my website etc and it's
helped me to live a better lifestyle
than I otherwise would do so yeah it's
definitely been a good thing I'm just
saying I'm not obviously not Zuckerberg
I'm not rolling in cash
I'm just an old guys and that's
hopefully where you can find some of
what I have to say useful the rest of
you internet marketers and online
entrepreneurs out there I am going to be
talking about ideas here that do apply
to pretty much any business models so
whether you have an e-book that you have
a subscription website you can still
benefit some of the things I'll mention
like minimally viable products routes to
market and creating something that's
unique and it stands out so again if
you're not an app developer one thing
that I found very useful in making my
Android apps is basic for Android which
is a IDE integrated development
environment it's not the one that most
people you've missed will use Android
studio or eclipse but basic for Android
essentially allows you to program in
Visual Basic to make Android apps to
save them as a PK file and it's very
liked it has a great supportive
community I love programming basic
that's why I learned to program and
originally on the jeddak's spectrum it
has no limitations you can even use Java
in line so you and there's nothing you
can't do you can import Java libraries
so like I say it's very likely when you
compile it stays very efficient the
files run well people make 3d games with
it so there's no limitation that just
makes it
easier it looks like this they get a bit
of code from one of my apps multiple
multitasking which we'll be talking
about in a moment so it's definitely
still code if you're someone who tries
away from programming this might not be
for you if you can't program at all
you're gonna find it tricky but if
you're looking to learn to program this
is actually a lot easier to learn than
is Java also probably slightly less
useful to learn because you won't be
able to do basic difference many
scenarios but learning one language
makes it much easier to learn the others
it's a good starting point I can program
in Java but this allows me to make a
spar more quickly and better quality
just because the workflow is much better
like say the community saves helpful you
can install onto the phone by polluting
the test and you can do live debugging
it's just really good sped up my
turnaround time for creating out hugely
so I recommend having a look and you can
see in the description are linked in my
full review of basic for Android and I
am selling it on the site I do get
Commission but you also get a discount
if you buy through my link so of course
I won't sound biased but the enemies and
I decided to support it was because I
believe in it so much I don't think I
could have had the success with my apps
without this program so check that out
that's just a little tip everything else
I'm going to talk about applies whether
you use basic for Android or whether you
use Eclipse or whether you use Android
studio so yeah don't worry too much
about that but if you're looking for
something that's light easy to get into
speeds up your process at the same time
is fully-featured so you're not you know
using an app builder and can't you know
access GPS for instance then basic for
Android is a great choice
before I talk to you about my successful
apps I'll talk to you about one that
wasn't so successful germination which
is a computer game I made basically I
tried to make the simplest game I could
make this was one in Java before I had
basic for Android and basically you
moved around a grid as a little germ and
it was puzzles because everything you
stepped on changed the way you moved and
yeah the graphics were poor and it
didn't sell very well I think it sold
like five copies I've made a newer
version which I thought
about later but yeah it wasn't exactly a
run away here and I put a fair amount of
effort into that but not too much and
that was my first that's my first tick
for you use the fail fast business model
fail fast means you create an app in the
minimum time you can you create a
minimally Viable Product
that's the MVP and then you release that
to your audience you can call it beta
you can make it free but what you're
doing is you're testing whether or not
there is an audience there who was
interested and whether or not you can
sell this product and that's so
important because I know so many people
who tell me because I've had a bit of
success with apps they always come up to
me and say hey I've got an idea for an
app what do you think and I'm like great
it sounds a great app although they
nobody they tell me what it is cause I
think everyone's trying to steal their
ideas like I don't have better stuff to
do thanks without us
rude anyways so they create their app
but they don't release their app they
create their app and then they tweak it
and they perfects it for about six years
and then when they release it and they
get four downloads they're crushed and
they go to a pit of despair and take up
alcoholism points is there's no point
investing all your time all your effort
or your money into an app that you think
is gonna be the next big thing before
you know that actually is gonna be the
next big thing a lot of these
productivity gurus they talk about
verifying your market first I don't
think necessarily do that just release
the app as soon as you can it doesn't
have to have all the bells and whistles
there's actually perfect it'll never be
perfect and if you find yourself
perfecting every little last bit
probably just means you're putting off
releasing because you're scared of
what's going to happen and the longer
you leave it the worse it's going to be
if it doesn't succeed so it released
apps fast so lots of stuff at the wall
to see what sticks remember you can
always update an app so there's no
reason for you not to release an app see
if it's accessible and if it is then
develop it further that's what I started
to do I released a lot more after that
and then that's when my big hit came
along so then I released a slew of other
apps things like writers keyboard which
was a different keyboard and tended for
writers things like spell check word
count this was before these were built
in too many of the apps that you'd use
as processors things like that just that
I thought maybe would have an audience
but none of them took off in a big way
something did make a few sales but again
I was very glad that I was going with
that fail-fast mentality at this point
because none of them stuck and
when I brought out did stick that was
multi screen multitasking
and the idea behind most screen
multitasking was I am a right so that's
my main job I was scratching my own itch
because I wanted to go to write on my
phone I thought wouldn't be awesome if I
could go for a run with nothing but my
phone in my pocket stop somewhere and a
foldable keyboard stop somewhere sit
down and do my work that was the dream
but the problem was that I often have to
write from a source so I need to have a
web page open next to the writing I'm
doing in order to be able to come up
with the content that I'm writing
unfortunately there's no way to do that
in Android obviously you can only run
one at full screen at a time unless
you've got a Galaxy Note which didn't
exist back then or one of the other
Samsung's and they didn't exist back
then and anyways they're still very
limited in terms of the apps you can
open so I wanted something I could use
to type next to a browser so originally
I thought how about split screen browser
and notepad so I created and they pad
just over the top of a browser so it
wouldn't be cool if I could watch a
movie while start browsing the web so I
started to make a secret flick between
the different things at the top and the
bottom so you could multitask in
different ways and then I was like hang
on I could have a desktop and launched
them in Windows that would be resizable
you could drag around the screen
basically have windows on a device so
they went from wanting to be able to
write next to a browser into coming up
with a way around the fact that you
couldn't have multiple apps running at
once this works because it was just one
app but it was one app that had the
capabilities of a browser of a notepad
of a video player of a final manager
drawing pass all these things all built
in and so you would open them in Windows
but it would still be one app you just
be able to move all these individual
elements around the screen I was the
first to come up with that solution and
I released it on to the Play Store
originally like to say the MVP fail fast
business model originally all I released
was a browser and a notepad that's all
it was in it but it was called multi
screen multitasking and mostly
multitasking the name is what made it
successful because people were looking
for a way to most test on their phones
that's what they were searching for
and while I they found my app so without
any need for me to promote it they start
getting a lot of sales and for a while I
was earning 35 to 40 quid that's about
80 to 90 dollars a day not doing any
work for it so it was on top of my usual
salary and I remember distinctly being a
house party noticing that success
watching the sales and just being like
wow this is awesome
I've actually stumbled upon something
that might be successful here the
question we need to ask is why was that
one successful and the others weren't
and the answer is the people are already
looking for there was only demand there
for something like this people wanted to
be able to impose tests on my phones
they're searching for the exact name I
used the keyword without really
realizing I had seen that people were
searching what someone's asking in the
play store but without really realizing
it was a keyword I used that as the
title so people were searching for it
finding it and over time obviously added
more and more features like I said now
it's got and they've had under Scott a
draw pads and a file manager and music
player and I also added the ability to
make desktop shortcuts which could also
be shortcuts to your your favorite
websites or your favorite files so in
many ways it would make you slightly
more productive on your phone that was
the idea anyways so yeah that's that
take off it petered down a little bit
now but that one still mix back 250 quid
for me a month I released it in many
different iterations so there's one
version that's a little bit easier
called split-screen multitasking where
you don't come actually resize the
windows there's a version for poem
there's a version for tablet by doing
this I'll add we would get the exact
version they won I also essentially can
market the same app for different times
so and it also means if everyone had a
problem before everyone I come down from
the Play Store I wouldn't completely cut
off my revenue from apps so yeah that is
how that's gone and that's been earning
just gradually gone down to about 250
pound a year a month but that's over the
course of these three and a half years
or three years roughly since I released
it so it's only well and say at one
point it was earning considerably over a
grand for me per month
obviously awesome I went a bit mental in
fact because I was so worried is gonna
suddenly blow up in my face with
something I became a bag of nerves
checking myself every two seconds that's
another story for another time now I'd
like to talk a little bit about I'm
coming up with the idea for apps so how
did I can't with the idea this is
something I like to call the step-back
technique and that's something I think
you can use in any business or any
project so the idea is with the
step-back technique
TM it's not three months so you can copy
it the idea is that you come up with an
idea something that you want or that
everyone wants so for instance when I go
man I wish my phone was able to run full
windows and he go what's the closest to
that that I can achieve so I can't
achieve that let's go step back what
might be achieved or let's go a bit step
back further than that so then you
create the closest thing you can to what
it was you're going for so for me that
was originally split the screen multi
browser a notepad but over time I
realized that I could do more and I
could make it much more like running
Windows on a phone and that's the same
thing you can do with most of these
projects once you start trying the most
basic attempt to what you're if you want
to do you can then start to add more to
it and you realize actually haven't come
quite place to making the thing I
originally wanted to make often so and
that's works then to create apps that
people are going to want because you're
creating the thing that everyone wanted
but couldn't have and you're creating
the next best thing and if you market
similar if you market it correctly give
it the right name then people will
search for it so that's just one little
trick I use come with new ideas for apps
what do I want to make let's see the
next thing that's important is marketing
and how you get these things to sell for
multi screen multitasking I never did
any marketing it was literally just the
fact that was called that that made it
successful but that was a bit of a fluke
if I'm honest Musquin was asking was
such a lucky name at the time and
Samsung were also soon after promoting
multi-screen multitasking on their
phones their version and mostly
multitasking and they actually
advertised it as that so that boosted my
sales hugely but I could say I was a
little bit right place right time I'm
not saying it can't be done the game but
but no I wouldn't rely on that as being
your main method so I started to look
for other things that everyone wants
that there was a route to market for
meaning a direct access to market
something has to come up with a was a
app for the oculus rift you could plug
in and you could view your pictures and
videos they didn't go so well and
unfortunately my computer died and I
lost the files that was awkward so it
wasn't the success it could be I'm not
recommending anyone download that but
that did get me quite a lot of sales at
the time and again it's because there
was something people were looking for on
the store it wasn't there yet
and again that's meant that there wasn't
really need to do any marketing though I
did do it a little so you've got to
think how do I differentiate myself if
you're going to just release an app that
does something cool but no one's really
looking for you're going to need to
invest a ton of money into marketing and
ask you a big company you're going to
struggle to make your app wowser that is
something to do with you know finding
friends that got the same interests
you're gonna have to you're gonna really
struggle to get people to find this to
be interested in it
you're gonna have to tell them what it's
about you're gonna have to tell them why
they should care and you're gonna have
to reach them you're gonna on a large
enough scale especially we've got a name
like wowzer like many people could
release these apps and have names there
just to produce because they want to
sound cool like you know toko weird
example the point is they just can't
with kind of vowel sounds and they call
that an app and then they wonder why no
one's searching for and funding it on
the Play Store and unless you have
millions for investment marketing I
would recommend creating something that
there's a clear need for a clear route
to market so a good way of doing it is
creating something for a small niche so
if you can find someone some group of
people who love like I made a free
running app and that had quite a few
hits that's before there are any other
free running apps on the store again
like in that case I'm making that for
small group of people that easy to
market to you just go to their forums
and again you're filling a niche that
hasn't been met for them yet so that's
the kind of thing you've got to do
you've got to say whoa why should anyone
care about this app you know and more
importantly how I'm gonna make them care
we're gonna find the people that would
care it's not enough to just release a
great app it's better than release about
app for a small audience that you can
market directly from a making money
perspect
titty design in a crowd of as well can
make easily that you can create a
minimally viable product for very fast
if you're coming up with an app that's
social that's gonna need lots of server
space that's gonna need you to team up
with the hot dog industry then all I can
say is good luck there might be great
for a big company but it shouldn't be
your first app for your first app try
and think what can I actually make that
serves a role there's going to be quick
to release when I have lots of ideas for
apps I write them down and then I
compare them in terms of which one is
the one that will potentially bring me
the most money which is the one that I
care about the most but also which is
what I can make the fastest and then I
find the one with the best scores across
the board and there's just no point in
coming up with a huge project for your
very first app that's going to involve
multiple I say stay away from social
current with something that's simple
quick easy a tool that you can put out
there and see if you've got a response
don't try and change the world with the
first app if you want to make money you
don't actually have to you know
throughout the rule book over time of
course multi screen multitasking started
to peter out in terms of the sales it
was making me still about two hundred
pounds to two hundred fifty pounds a
month it continues to you today but not
quite the same thousand pound plastered
it was making when it first released i
want to have another success under my
belt i wanted to see if i could create
something that people would like a
second time i didn't want to be just a
one-hit wonder so i started looking for
ideas for my next big app and i just
struggled to find something that was
again such a unique idea that people
were looking for and it didn't help as
well that monster good multitasking
people were releasing free versions of
and just given mine away for free and
copying my original design specs so yeah
none of that had wood sales i needed
something new one idea I came up with
was instead of going it alone I could
try them team up with someone and work
with someone who had different skills
from me and also their own audience and
I'd long been a fan of a guy called cold
fusion that's known as a YouTube channel
and he releases videos on technology and
they're incredibly well edited and it's
helped
to really stand out he's built a huge
audience and not only did he do kind of
tech documentaries he also did a lot of
app customization and he had this design
for home screen using a bunch of
different apps that he called boxes so I
approached him and I thought this would
be a great opportunity and to reach big
audience with an app and potentially
this would be profitable because if we
decided to sell it I thought that would
always be up to him and he did want to
of course because we put a lot of work
into it that meant that we had this
route to market ready-made a huge
audience that loved his stuff and would
trust his recommendation rightly so and
so yeah that was instead of me creating
an app and then looking for an audience
this time i was finding an audience on
it for a long time he's really good at
design this wasn't quite the same
minimally Viable Product but we did know
already there was already verified
because people were installing his boxes
launcher we didn't have the worry that
people people were rather they were
doing his roxas home screen and we knew
the launch would likely be successful so
he didn't have the risk of spending all
this time on something don't be
interested in we had a ready-made market
we had proven interest and as a result
one released that one it was a game a
big success it had you know several
thousand downloads in the first month
again its trailed off slightly but every
time we released an update he checks bad
on his YouTube channel we get a nice
little spike in sales again so again
it's just great to be reaching a big
audience with an app and this time the
system was different it was finally
something to work with and creating
something with them that's a idea you
can use as well so if you want to create
an app that's in Fitness maybe look into
finding a partner who already has a lot
of influence when it comes to fitness
already has a big audience look for a
blogger who talks about fitness if you
want to make an app that just
productivity then before you create it
find somebody that you could work with
it has that route to market and can help
you that's a very different strategy to
the one where you're creating something
and then marketing it instead like I say
you're finding the market and creating
the app tailored for that and you can
always branch out as the later date or
you can put more work into
that audience say that's another
strategy that's worked for me and
probably can work for you as well and
the next thing I'd like to talk about is
monetization how do you actually make
money from an app and this is something
some people will disagree with but I'm
gonna say to make money from an app unit
in charge for the app and that might
sound kind of intuitive a lot of people
think the best way to make money from
app is to release it for free and have
ads showing on it however I don't think
I'd have made anywhere near what I've
made from apps if I'd gone with that
tact the reason being that when you
release an app with advertisement on it
you normally get say a cent if someone
clicks on it or maybe a cent if a
thousand people look at it or get to
look at a thousand times so now you're
looking at and think about it yourself
happen do you actually click an ad when
you're on an app it's accidental when
you do and it's not very common
you probably avoid it as much as you can
so that that means that you're gonna
need thousands of people using your app
on a regular basis in order for you to
make any money from advertising so if
your Angry Birds great you'll you'll you
know be minted but if you're anything
less than that then you're going to
struggle to make that kind of money
think about your own phone use how many
apps you use on an actual daily basis
the answer is probably like Facebook and
your camera you probably don't use
anything else on a daily basis
so if you want to really make money from
apps you need to become as big and as
important as Facebook to this phone user
that's starting to get unlikely so on
the other hand if you charge for your
app I charge about one pound twenty to
sixty P depending on the app and whether
or not I'm running information if you
charge for it then you could you can get
people to pay just that one-off fee but
if you get the thousand people
downloading at one pound twenty yeah and
of course there are some fees taken by
Google if we get a thousand people
taking them paying one pound twenty and
you get about a pound from that you've
earned a thousand pounds and that's you
know not small money and it's much
easier to get people to buy a one pound
20 app than it is to get to by say a 30
dollar ebook which you might be used to
if you're an internet marketer or a $30
you know something else so what am I
going to be doing next what I'm gonna be
doing next is building my own audience I
have my website the Pioneer and this
YouTube channel
good Lyonya and through these I will be
promoting my new apps I create my own
audience I have my own route to market
hopefully I'll be older and gain the
trust of my audience and build some
authority by writing good posts I'm
mostly in the self-improvement
bodybuilding brain enhancement
transhumanism niche if that's a leash
the biohacking me Chester bass and so
that's what I'm gonna create openes my
next app and of course I think there is
a suitable market for most remote
testing which have some big plans for
I'm going to be building on more in
future I'll keep working with Cochise
janani's
boxes app and I'm sure he'll promote
history charity but yeah that's the
thing I'm gonna be working on Nexus
creating my own platform because that's
a slightly bigger that's a slightly
longer tail version of how you do this
if you don't have a room to market you
can find immediately if you don't have
an idea for an app that scratches a
niche that everyone has then what you
can do instead is to create your own
audience through a blog or through a
video and as you gradually gain more and
more followers and momentum then you can
release something
often people release an e-book which is
fine but a lot of them buy ebooks and
people try to lock for them if you
release an app I'm hoping or several
apps that help people with the things
they're trying to do and if you can
write about it in your content in a way
that makes it sound engaging and it's
not expensive then I think that's a good
little business model so that's what
I'll be doing that's what I'll be
working on now it's just focusing on the
blog building up the momentum to release
my next and then they'll be hopefully an
audience they're waiting for it so
that's another strategy you can try I
hope you've found some of what I've said
in this video helpful if you have any
other ideas or tips on how to make money
from app then please do share them in
the comment section and if this has
helped you in any way please like share
and subscribe I'll be uploading more
videos of course and I'll be back more
to my usual topics of bodybuilding
nootropics I'm looking at releases
something to do with brain plasticity
soon and
one on training like Batman but I will
also be doing more on technology and on
productivity because I think all this
ties them together I think you have to
improve every aspect to improve any
aspect in this case in particular
working on apps and having this passive
income has allowed me more time more
freedom and more energy to spend working
out working on my other projects and
looking into things like brain training
and just also living a much more free
and healthy in my opinion lifestyle
rather than commuting into a busy
crowded stressful office so if you think
it all ties in together that's why I'll
be talking about this sort of thing from
time to time on the channel thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one bye for now